jokic thought about the three spins into
the paint over the top of towns off
balance he missed it
offensive rebound Gordon boy he used all
of his leaping ability
they have let these guys play
I don't know five-point game Edwards the
kick Alexander Walker splash
even Big Town got him
Edwards around a screen to the rat goes
left hand off glass we are tied it's
down that three and then Edwards with an
incredible left-handed hook shot
two-point nuggets lead Buck 17 left in
regulation
towns
extends got it we're tied again
60 Seconds
Porter jokic here comes the two-time MVP
back rim no joke again
they'll get it to Murray 30 seconds
jokic the little hesitation puts it in
and he's failed
and jokic's putting him on his bench
thank you
free throw line right there
and then probable finish there
do they have one last push here in
Denver Conley fakes fires got it
elected not to call for time here comes
Edwards quickly kicks near side Prince
no offensive rebound Edwards back up and
he lays it in
no timeouts left for Minnesota here we
go Conley looking for Edwards finally
gets it to him Edwards launches
no and Denver survives
and they have punched their ticket to
the Western semis
Edwards had a chance
just a little bit too much